كل الشركات حاليا تبحث عن ماذا بعد
الهواتف الذكيه ليه لان عشان تستمر في
تحقيق الارباح عشان تستمر في الحصول على
مال وغيرها فلازم تكتشف الجديد التقارير
تشير الى ان الهواتف الذكيه قد تكون
موجوده خلال سنوات بسيطه وبعدها تختفي زي
ما اختفت تقنيات تراه من حياتنا تذكر السي
دي والتلفزيون
ستجلب المعلومات امام وجهك بالضبط
في ابحاث كثيره تتكلم من النظارات قد تكون
هي المستقبل تمام لكنه حتى الان هو مكتشف
انا جربت احد النظارات الجديده اللي تعرض
لك رسائل كذا يعني الان في في الاستديو قد
يكون مو موجود
راح يكون موجود
كويسه في تجارب بتتكلم من الخرائط بدل لا
تعتمد نواره تكون موجود عندك النظاره
التجربه الحاليه اثبتت انها تحتاج شويه
وقت حتى تكون تجربه ناجحه بشكل جدا كبير
وقد يكونوا مستخدم ما يتقبلها وتستمر
الهواتف الذكيه في تواجدها لكن قد تكون
هواتف ذكيه موجوده بطريقه مختلفه ان تكون
قابله للطي احنا نتكلم عن هواتف قابله
للطي في استثمارات كبيره جدا الهواتف
الذكيه تكون قابله للطي لانه لون الهواتف
الذكيه صارت قابله للطي فانت عندك راح
يكون جهاز جوال وكمبيوتر وتابلت وشاشه في
نفس الوقت ليه اذا جهازي قابل للطيفه انا
افتحها
بشكل كبير واضيفه على اكسسوار خارجيه يصير
كمبيوتر تمام وكل شيء صار ايضا طيب افتح
بشكل اكبر يكون عندي شاشه اكبر استخدمها
ويكون عندي النظام الخاص فيني التجارب
كلها مفتوحه المستقبل للهواتف الذكيه راح
يكون مبهر وممكن ما يشوف هواتف ذكيه خلال
العشر سنوات القادمه